question j'ai l'impression que c'est un
traumatisme pour vous cette paire qui
niche est clair et est ce que ça a
changé votre regard sur la police
voilà c'est cher mais j'aurais cru
qu'une chose pareille est donc possible
donc ya eu un avant et un après pour la
police mais solidement sur le plan
personnel je ne croyais pas tout ce
qu'on me disait moi je vous parle cash
là je ne croyais pas j'ai été traumatisé
j'ai été élu en banlieue je voyais bien
qu'il y avait des jeunes c'était il ya
déjà un moment s'il ya il ya 20 ans bon
il y avait des jeunes qui étaient
continuellement contrôler jusqu'à ce
qu'il craque alors évidemment les
retrouve au post le père m'appelait
j'allais au poste le commissaire me dit
ah non il ya en garde à vue on savait
pas pourquoi tout le monde avait peur
jusqu'au lendemain matin ou alors lâché
d'accord mais je me disais bon peut-être
quitter conne bon j'avais du mal à
croire tout ça et je n'ai jamais été
anti flics bon parce que la tradition
qu'est la mienne la culture politique
c'était bon plutôt la loi et l'ordre bon
pas n'importe quelle loi mais l'ordre en
tout cas depuis cette perquisition
et puis ce jour là je vois des gens
arriver et bon c'était un abus de
pouvoir au plus d'accord ou pas d'accord
avec moi c'est pas le sujet mais je suis
député je suis président d'un groupe
d'opposition
et quand je dis je veux rentrer dans mon
local vous avez un gars qui met la main
sur son pétard et qui me dit je suis
armé monsieur en en montrant son truc
tricolore alors je lui dis la république
c'est moi monsieur la république c'est
moi c'est moi qui suis élu du peuple est
un et vous et vous aurez on sait c'est
pas pareil
donc je oui c'est un traumatisme mais je
suis pas le seul - mélenchon c'est ce
traumatisme et jérôme rodriguez
je suis sûr qu avant de se prendre un
truc dans la figure lui aussi il aurait
dit enfin faut pas exagérer comme
monsieur laporte et ça parlera demain il
a oui bah parce que ces délits qu'ils
ont soit eu trop dans la vie pas trop
forcer
les stations jeunes armés alors vous
avez une manifestation pour la police il
y avait 1 valenciennes un policier
demain qu'ils étaient victimes voilà de
quoi de quoi dans les gares situées à la
sortie de charlie ce pauvre malheureux
j'ai été maître des fleurs comme les
autres et ça c'est à l'époque mais
maintenant je n'en ferai pas qu'on tue
quelqu'un monsieur hanouna
mais que les choses soient bien claires
en toute situation
je répète en toute situation je suis
contre la violence et je le dis à mes
jeunes camarades j'ai connu quand
j'étais plus jeune
le soutien à telle ou telle forme de
violence politique auquel on était
associé mais s'il fallait voir outre
outil contre pinochet contre le général
bender des gens comme ça et bien
aujourd'hui je dirais non
il faut pas faire ça parce que ça ne
nous mènent nulle part ce qu'il faut
c'est que le grand nombre soit avec nous
et pour ça pas de violence et je le dis
entonné l'hymne autres ont été tués vous
avez peur de la police aujourd'hui avec
ce qui vous est arrivé vraiment bien sûr
enfin ils sont venus à siéger deux fois
mon parti politique et je devrais pas
avoir peur des sujets déjà le dise de
moi comme ça que vous avez vu la liste
où il y en a qui dit on va mettre des
chandelles on commence par lui en
parlant de moi
enfin mehdi vivait dans lequel jean
l'excellence et la réalité c'est un
navet j'enlève no show ouais si vous
êtes président de la république en 2022
candidats les surmonter ça ah mais ça
c'est très facile à faire je suis un
homme j'ai beaucoup d'expérience j'en ai
déjà vécu d'autres je me suis fâché avec
des gens pire est consigné tout à leur
main dit qu'on était fâché il ya des
fois on est attaché d'autrefois où on
est en colère
pas pareil et d'autres fois où on
proteste donc comme président de la
république il est clair que je
rétablirai une police républicaine
je trouverais un ministre de l'intérieur
qui n'utilisent pas la police pour en
faire faire des démonstrations de force
comme le fait aujourd'hui le préfet
l'allemand qui d'ailleurs sera invité à
laisser vous avez instauré la garde de
quelqu'un d'autre
excusez l'instant la garde nationale moi
j'étais partisan d'une garde nationale
monsieur marche
merci de me passer le louis mais je suis
partisan de quelque chose qui soit plus
une garde républicaine c'est à dire que
tout ce qui concerne la vie en commun je
ne dis pas la police judiciaire c'est un
autre métier
il ya plein de métiers dans la police la
police judiciaire c'est ceux qui courent
après les criminels après qui font des
enquêtes premier truc donc cela c'est à
part c'est encore de police
moi je vous parle la police à laquelle
on a à faire nous verrons bien
l'année a été plus bas on va voir partir
là dessus et vient la garde républicaine
serait une bonne chose dans lesquels
aussi y aurait des jeunes gens du conte
argent parce que comme ça tout le monde
à prendre et en quoi ça consiste à
maintenir la paix pas faire les cowboys
maintenir la paix pas faire peur aux
gens
pas intimidé pas contrôlé dix fois la
même personne
je ne vous dis pas que tous les
policiers le fond je vous dis que
certains le font ils